speaking of climate activism globalism
and censorship let's shift this to Bill
Gates now you all know Bill Gates Bill
Gates created Microsoft Bill Gray Gates
created Windows which if you're of a
certain age you remember all the pop-ups
all the viruses you remember my main
memory of Windows Windows 95 is the
paint program you probably have to paint
program right and you could fill the
whole thing with the color and then you
could put other colors it was incredible
anyway he becomes a billionaire now he
owns more Farmland in the United States
than anyone else he somehow also thinks
he's a covet expert and he has been
advocating for more ESG programs now ESG
I'm going to tell you a bit more about
it in just a moment we've talked about
it before Glenn Beck wrote a spectacular
book about it's called environmental
social and government
programs in effect but here's Bill Gates
advocating for more ESG collaborations
we need to innovate to make the cost of
doing it the Green Way a far less than
it is today to get emissions all the way
to zero not just the rich countries but
the entire world it's not so much who
you don't invest in it's who you do
invest in driving Innovation with some
incentives like the tax credits that the
US has now that's the right policy mix
we did get three bills that went through
Congress two were bipartisan one was a
Reconciliation Bill all of which
increased the funding for climate in
total about 500 billion extra dollars so
the combination of these new bills plus
private efforts like Breakthrough energy
catalysts I mean you're gonna you're
gonna get to go to a lot of plant
openings where people say okay this is
green steel this is green cement this is
green hydrogen and a lot of those will
be placed in places where the
hydrocarbon jobs are going away so
people get a sense that this is a a just
transition all right so let me be clear
about one thing which is that I really
think the Bill Gates is an evil person I
I think that the power and the money has
gone to his head where he thinks it is
it is his divine right to reorganize or
re-jigger the world in a way that he
wishes it to be the idea not only first
off that you would say to any country
but you take okay let's take the rich
countries first because he addressed
rich countries they would say you have
to do this to your economy you have to
make it more green because we wish you
too well every nation should decide that
for themselves that's the problem with
globalization right that's number one
but putting aside the rich countries the
poor countries right now that are going
through their industrial revolutions if
you take a country you could take India
or China that are years behind us in
their industrial revolutions that are
using coal and these other things what
right do we have or the globalists have
to say no you cannot do that and by the
way fossil fuels are still to this very
moment getting more people out of
poverty and doing more good for the
world than they are bad we've done many
shows on this Jordan Peterson has talked
about a lot Bjorn Lumberg this this is
something that is real whether they like
it or not